I look like Steve Jobs got a Pinterest
makeover amazingly talented singers and
actors gathered to celebrate other
tremendously talented singers and actors
they all wore things
it's a Tony Awards red carpet fashion
review by me the most musically capable
person on the planet also forewarning
I'm not very familiar with the Broadway
and musical world but I've done some
research and I wrote some notes Laura
Benanti she loves me that's the name of
a play not her emotional feelings
towards me grace helbig as a person
education let's get into this Jesse
Tyler Ferguson and Justin Makita look at
these handsome you guys look so happy
and so handsome
Jack dammit oh sorry that was the sound
of my lady boner Megan Hilty let me
refer to my notes was nominated for Best
Actress and noises off I don't know why
I sorry it was my boner going back I
don't know why I feel the need to tell
you that I have done research on these
people I don't do it in any other
fashion review but I just feel I'm
overcompensating Megan's in the plane
noises off and hats off to your
beautiful upkeep of your roots and your
boobs you know you can't spell roots or
boobs without Oh beautiful
who's Owen du Bois who's us from Orange
is the new black she was not nominated
for anything that I found in my research
you look like you put something up your
cooter and you're keeping it a secret
from all of us don't know why but that's
the vibe I'm getting from this photo
it's either that or just pure
unadulterated confidence I don't know I
have a very difficult time knowing the
difference between those two feelings
are you hiding something in your cooter
or are you just confident I don't know
Allison Williams I think this is cool I
cannot tell if her right leg is broken
or if this is just so there
symmetrical jumpsuit her facial
expression it could go either way
broken leg or fashion but your clutch
looks like it's made out of duct tape
and that is very very relatable cute
Glenn Close and Andrew Lloyd Webber they
look like when they were way too young
they got drunk and started to fool
around and I do not go well
you also look a little bit like toddlers
that got reversed Benjamin Button and
they're sneaking into an adult event
trying to make sure that no one knows
that you're both actually six years old
nailed it
Gloria and Emilio Estefan this is great
because if I saw this photo and no one
told me what year this photo was taken
in I would have no idea
cute Karolina Kurkova is there and her
face is as confused as all of us maybe
she thought Tony Awards a second
radiation of Tommy Hilfiger awards you
look beautiful and sleek and very much
like a model come and you know what I
wish was common this charisma this looks
like the nicest man in the universe
sorry there goes my boner can aren t bit
I don't know if this is how you say his
name but he has been oh let me refer to
my notes aunt eva is a Broadway star
he's been in such productions as rent
catch me if you can ask Athens both of
your asses look great in that beautiful
tuxedo aren t bit a double a is an
errand stand for SS and Jessica Lange
you look like you would emotionally tear
me apart stunning Michelle William other
end of the emotional spectrum you look
like you are waiting for someone to tear
you apart
emotionally beautiful very vulnerable
cute Neil Patrick Harris and David
Burtka is that you say your last name
you watch these videos leave a comment
down below we got some rod Roddy
elegance some Breaking Bad chic you put
that together you got a spectrum of look
something for everyone with this couple
you guys please be my friend
Josh Groban is there been Josh Groban
kindest eyes in the biz Josh Groban
oh I'm sorry goose I didn't realize that
you were president of the Josh Groban
fan club uh yeah he has kind eyes and he
looks like the Paul read-up music Sara
Bareilles Sara Bareilles wrote the music
for waitress was nominated for Best
Musical I do research and that's the
part you care about in this video
they're gross you look like you are
going to the prom at the Renaissance
Fair you look like you are going off
into the woods of interest to be married
how cute Carole King you're okay
is the creator of a beautiful the Carole
King musical so I have Google I want is
Carole King 74 and you're wearing heels
like that at 74 that's very very
impressive as a sport that I cannot
compete in even now James Corden and
Julia Carey ha you guys look great the
saddest part of this photo is that this
is James Corden's wife and she exists
and she's beautiful and I'm so happy for
them Jane Krakowski this look from the
vagina models because that's a deep V
Laura Benanti to nominate for Best
Actress in a leading role of a musical I
think I love this dress of your hair
color of makeup like all of it it's like
the floral on your dress is looking at
the rose wall behind you and go on Kivu
you very much Justin Guarini
I included Justin Guarini in this mix
because holy shiz Justin Guarini I did
not recognize when you trim the hedges
you find a beautiful bush lin-manuel
Miranda Chuck did you check I don't even
know you and I'm so happy for you and I
want to know you I just want to be
inspired more by you
good job skin good job I love when
talented people create amazing thanks
Danielle Brooks Danielle was nominated
for Best Actress in a Musical for the
color purple and that color Navy like
the color purple
good on you you look gorgeous Anna
Wintour and her daughter Cynthia areevo
who won Best Actress in a Musical for
the color purple looks like a winner you
just look like a winner
your dress looks a little bit like it's
a Project Runway Project where they make
dresses out of like silk candy bar
wrappers but it's gorgeous it looks
delicious
Lupita and Jung go it was nominated for
Best Actress in a play for the plate
eclipse and your dress looks like has
gummy worms glued all over it and I love
it
I love sugar I love sugar I like fashion
I love sugar they're my thoughts for the
Tony Awards red carpet fashions let me
know what you guys thought I know I
probably missed some people that you
guys wanted me to talk about and
apologize I'm doing the best I can and
if you're upset your blood sugar levels
are probably low so I encourage you to
eat just kidding on that note please
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already that would be really wonderful
of you and um that's it
I don't know Andrew Rannells this guy
wit looks like a baby you look like a
baby your face looks like a baby
very handsome baby you look like you
have a baby doll face as a grown man
it's a baby it's that's a doll baby face
on a grown man and it is still it's
handsome and it's adult but it's a baby
it's a baby and it's round and it's
shiny it's a baby face and I think you
broke me I think you broke me cute